hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast welfare first presented
by Tim McGuire life sciences director
agenda Life Sciences
I am Alexis Corrales of laberd's and I
will be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by agenda Life
Sciences for more information about our
sponsor visit a gentle life sciences com
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen well answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on that
accreditation button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen and follow the process to
obtain your credits please join me in
welcoming Tim McGuire I will now turn
the presentation over to him
many thanks Alexis and thank you for
giving us the opportunity to give you
all an overview of our welfare first
program
so just a little bit about me to put
some context to it and I'm one of the
directors gender with over 20 years
experience in the laboratory and sector
working in a range of areas in combating
scientific recruitment both as lab
animal scientists and general scientific
recruitment contract placement of staff
across a number of facilities in Europe
as well as looking up for our facility
management division what does that mean
because I know a number of you on this
seminar will be involved in facility
management we manage two pharmaceutical
companies to universities and three
multitalented facilities and the one
thing that binds the business together
is people so we started this program
three or four years ago and since then
obviously with changes in the industry
more pressure on biotech farmer to look
at the way they do research it's now
become commonplace within the industry
to consider the people looking after the
animals and this was first and foremost
in our agenda really when we started
this philosophy to tie in with our
culture of care a number of years ago so
in terms of some of the things we're
going to talk about today just really
talk about the integrity of research
people are concerned about
reproducibility of data people are
concerned about animal welfare but most
importantly for us we were concerned
about the people who looked after the
animals and how looking after them could
contribute towards perhaps better
research certainly a better culture of
care and most importantly particularly
in Europe and the UK in particular where
there's been a move towards more
openness how we could actually display
that within the marketplace so these are
some of the things that were talking
about and I think I mentioned before and
certainly for a number of you the most
important people in their
your staff and your people and the way
that we look after them tends to lead
into the research and the word is coming
out the other side when one is preparing
a presentation like this one doesn't
want to state the obvious but it was
important just to really confirm what is
integrity mean and there's a nice but
the nice saying really about integrity
about being honest and having strong
moral principles and I think all of us
who work in the lab or animal sector
research integrity and looking after the
animals underpins all of that but also
as we've seen from a number of
infiltrations over the last few years
that it's about doing the right thing
all of the time
open any door and go through and be
comfortable so the key for us as a
business was how did we link that
to our overall culture of care and how
did we link all of the staff that we had
like a number of you your staff will be
spread across many facilities we in
particular one of the drivers for us to
develop our welfare first program came
to the result of we thought we were
doing a great job offering a newsletter
from head office telling everybody about
how the business was doing but number of
the technicians felt that it wasn't
really giving them what they wanted in
terms of information about the business
information animal welfare so when we
when we went back to basics we were
looking at combining what we would say
all of us are our traditional drivers
for lab animal science how do we reduce
the number of animals how can we refine
how can we replace and that still
remains center among most animal
facilities philosophy be ethical review
when the work is reviewed or the moment
that the scientist selects their paper
and decides what to do these three hours
were key what we had a problem how did
we and given that we're providing a
service to clients how do we marry up
the three hours with our three core
value values of respect reputation and
responsibility and so given the culture
of our business and the culture of our
animal technicians we wanted really to
look at research integrity and put that
in the middle of this program
so I mentioned before about the drivers
for the business what we had to do as a
business involved with a whole host of
clients across the Europe and globally
we look to try and build our values
because the biggest challenge for
technicians is common standard an
expectation that's very easy to achieve
and I know a number of you will be
tuning into this webcast will understand
about the importance of a culture of
care current expectations and common
standards and this is in place in a
large number of animal facilities with
standard operating procedures training
records recognition we have the
challenges of businesses trying to make
that work across a whole host of
facilities as well as across as well as
a host of contract technicians who sit
within a number of different facilities
so the important thing for us was how
did we look to develop that standard
quality and that standard culture of
care in amongst all of those different
facilities what does world fair
consistency meaning we know what we
talked about and how do you deliver that
day-in day-out particularly against a
backdrop of people being different in
within different facilities etc but of
course as we've seen across the globe
over the last few years and people that
aren't don't quite share the same views
of animal research I've done a number of
expose days and we felt that we needed
to have a clearly stated tangible
commitment to animal welfare that was
painted in our contract rather than
leave that to individual and businesses
where our contract technicians sat so it
was quite a dilemma for us to try and
marry out the needs of our different
clients with the needs of us as a
business and as I mentioned before we
are a people business so they were some
of the drivers about welfare first once
we started our program
I think it was important for us to
understand that we were talking about
people but we also need to ensure that
we put the world fair ends of animals
front and center trial align that with
the expectations in different businesses
so we went for a strategic review of how
we as contractors can deliver excellent
welfare and I think there was the
feeling and certainly now I see more
literature about recognizing that the
work of a liberal animal technician is a
stressful one the day to day care of
animals the overarching responsibility
the review of ethical papers the
determining vent points all of those
things contribute to quite a stressful
environment and so it's important for us
to recognize with our program that
having that additional pressure of staff
in unusual environments meant that we
had to deliver excellent welfare you can
see there on the slide you know we have
over 100 technicians
across a number of facilities in Europe
and that was important for us to reach
out to them connect with them engage
with them as well as actually share some
some ideas about welfare and best
practice and when we talk about
protecting the integrity of research I
think that that's the aim for every
organization that we work with but how
did we do it across all of those
different facilities so of course we're
very much here today to just tell you
about our journey we know that a lot of
units have this philosophy in place and
and there will be different elements of
it what we try to do is feed it right
through our organization and reflect our
culture of care generally
so when we looked at welfare first the
most important thing was to start
thinking simplistically about what the
animal needs they're fairly well defined
and there won't be anything and
shattering for you on the next few
slides food and water they gaze on with
suppliers obviously temperature humidity
within the unit green bedding
etc the list goes on sufficient air
changes health checks you'll know all of
these has very much standard procedures
but it's very well defined about what
the animal wants with it an animal unit
we all have challenges of times with the
temperature and the humidity and but
there should be no doubt about health
checks and the handling and the courses
etc the socializing socialization of the
animals but actually welfare first is
really about looking after the people so
the people that look after the animals
are a very diverse Bunch
animal technicians veterinarians
researchers we should have cheers and
claps and boos at this point depending
upon where you sit within the
organization home office trainers cage
wash maintenance all of these different
people that interact in the lab animal
profession have a key part to play on
how the people feel etc so we spoken
about what animal needs and we spoken
obviously about the importance of the
different the different types of people
within that framework but you could
argue that this is almost integral in
any business but when we're looking for
people for our organizations I'm sure
you will face the same challenge
certainly in the UK we have gaps in
incapabilities and some of the younger
people come through we want our staff
and not sure you do interest animals
welfare qualifications would be great
people want to be developed
I think we fit increasingly as well and
I think the openness agenda certainly in
Europe has helped this a clear position
on the use of animals
people generally want effective
communication knowledge support all of
the things this is a particular one that
I've just raised up the opportunity to
raise concerns and one of the challenges
and for every organization is what does
good look like and what do I do or say
if I'm not happy with something I think
you know given some of the recent
controversies with different industries
about what's acceptable behavior what
isn't and I think our industry is ahead
of the game in terms of understanding
that that people need the ability to
raise concerns from an animal welfare
perspective as well as a person
perspective and going forward our
professional memberships career
development obviously people want the
people to they're dealing with in
integral so there are things that people
want and they're the things that animals
need so the key for us in terms of a
welfare first program was how do we pin
all of those things together and it
starts with very clear advertisements
about the type of people that we want in
our industry that meets our criteria
secondly we developed welfare first
contracts and not just contracts work to
a of employment or confidentiality
agreements with clients but actually a
welfare contract that our staff sign
that will tell them you know how they
can look after the animals and what's
important to them
the second thing for us in any framework
and again I know this will be embedded
in the culture of a number of
organizations watching this presentation
is the care for the technician what does
that look like on a day to day basis
are we meeting their needs are we
addressing some of their concerns etc
training and development is key we've
certainly seen with the transposition of
the EU directive the importance on
having up to date training and
records which reflect the skill base I
think that gives us all confidence and
it within our facility about the
capability of the people and certainly
in our instance where we're moving
technicians around the UK to fulfill
different contractual obligations it's
important for the client to understand
skill set of the people that are coming
to them
recognition I think is important I think
any and professional development of any
individual in any business would be key
to this in terms of we want to define
career path and certainly the i-80 into
animal technology and your version of a
less in the US and is working very hard
in terms of them developing career
pathways and has been doing that for a
number of years through and the training
modules etc and now reflects some of the
work that you're doing in the US and on
a global basis for the eilat program in
terms of recognizing the step changes
that people can take good communication
is key and I think there's always
challenges with what what people define
is with the communication and but I
certainly think where animal welfare is
concerned with communication and within
the workplace and what's acceptable
behavior arising is very very key and it
also security assured unfortunately
we're working industry where there are a
number of people that don't share our
views and they're not perhaps as
passionate about and us as animal
welfare so we need to be ensured that
we're screening people to the right
level and and that we're asking the
right question to interview etc I think
it's key to be very upfront with and
applications and the way that you frame
advertisements so there's no surprise
when the people join your organization
so in terms of the additional integrity
what other things our staff require what
what do we do and we have some value
Awards points we have an annual
technician of the year we make sure that
all of our staff are trained on on Home
Office and importantly for me and
philosophically you know clear behavior
moral and legal responsibilities
irrespective of the level of the the
individual within the organization so
there will she sign the world fair first
contract and most importantly they
understand where to go if they
any concerns or if they have anything
that that concerns them about what
they've seen or just understanding of
the way that different organizations and
run their business etc and we're also
able to offer annual training bank
accounts professional memberships
training in compliance roles etc and a
number of promotional career
developments and one of the key things
that we've found in the industry over
the last few years is the importance of
giving good social media advice and and
helping and assisting our staff with
what's acceptable behavior are both in
the workplace and what's acceptable to
talk about and the other side of our
businesses is on pre-employment
screening and what we've seen in a host
of and industries is the importance on
working with the employee to ensure that
they're screened effectively at the
start their career and particularly in a
case of us and replacing technicians out
into the marketplace so we spoke all as
well about the importance of openness in
a bio animal science and as you'll be
aware certainly in Europe there's much
more of a commitment to openness and and
many many universities under the Freedom
of Information Act now publish their
data on their websites I think that's
helped I think it's very important for
us as an organization both providing
staff and amazing facilities that we try
and get the young generation of
technicians through I know that there
are a number of outreach programs
globally and for companies
we tend to concentrate on the broader
animal courses and recruit a number of
us start from there we deliver a lot of
welfare first talks and with one of the
interesting things for us was always the
dilemma when we're recruiting laboratory
animal technicians for our business that
we want people to be passionate about
animal welfare
sometimes that passion can roll over
into supporting crafts groups that would
be deemed to be and not supportive of
animal research so it's important for us
both as a recruiter and as a person that
places and staffing and other facilities
that were able to validate somebody's
background questioned them have a chat
about the differences between being
passionate about animal welfare where
that message freezing tablets and
concerns about lab animal science so
we've done a number of welfare surveys
where really it's confirmed what we
thought we knew that of course people
that work in the lab animal space are
very passionate about the use of
laboratory animals the use of any
animals sometimes and that's reflected
in their personal life as well so for us
it was important from an openness
commitment to be honest about who we are
be very upfront as a business about that
the market that we supply so we have an
active social media presence which helps
that and we've delivered welfare first
talks one of my colleagues normal more
to a number of you may know I'm managing
director is delivered number of welfare
first talks in the US Australia Brazil
and of course to a number of the UK
organizations this is our own position
statement and that's on our website and
we really feel passionately about that
about placing ourselves front and center
but the businesses over 20 years old and
we've always been at the forefront of
your bio to animal science within the UK
and interestingly enough in a world are
adverse we tend to make sure that and
people understand what we do and that
helps us to attract the right type of
person for our business
tomorrow examples here I give you
scientists director to review that what
we found is that we're looking for
people with integrity and having an
advertisement in this style helps us to
ensure that we get the right people who
can
do the job to them to the best of their
effect
the other key part which I'm aware of
and particularly and given my age while
my daughter's would say slightly
differently but the most important thing
is to engage on social media and I think
and one of the things we've seen in
particularly with the labyrinth
organization is the ability to reach out
and actually get with people through
different mediums so the important thing
for us in terms of increasing the and
knowledge of the Broad Channel etc in
the work that we do is to ensure that we
we engage social media interact with the
kids at college keep information flowing
through where they can see the benefits
of the virtual animal science and
obviously from our own perspective
and you'll all have very active and web
sites one of the questions sort of open
questions which somebody might want to
pick up at the end of the presentation
is you know how look at the way your
institution and talked about the work
that it does and is it front and center
on the university's website on the
academic Institute's on the
pharmaceutical sectors website is it
tucked away doesn't give people the
information that they need to feel
comfortable cetera it's quite important
for you as businesses to engage with our
and audience and this has come a long
way but certainly we see culturally and
there are big differences still between
and different parts of the world and
partly driven by concerns over security
on my head just to be balanced and the
most important thing is to be open and
honest about businesses that that we run
how we use animals and reporting the
numbers obviously feel a bit more tricky
for a private organization but it's
important to continually engage and as
we know there are a number of good
global organizations who help us to do
that and
mentioned before about our dedicated
student section we find the biggest
challenge for our industry is actually
attracting a certain demographic so
social media is a good way for us to
reach out and and the IAT do an awful
lot of our outreach work within the UK
again not dissimilar to a lass on a
global basis but is here I'm labeling
this point particularly because one of
the things that I hear a lot of what I
map about is the dearth of youngsters
coming through but it's more a question
of educating them and at the college
stage and I certainly know the ayat in
working very hard now on apprenticeship
schemes and to reach out to more
youngsters so I mentioned before about
them and we spoke and to start the
presentation about some of the drivers
one of the things that was interesting
and just a like somebody to consider and
we've all seen a number of newsletters
I'm sure that we're all involved with
different sports clubs clubs outside of
work as well as work itself and
everybody says that a new vet is a great
idea and then everybody walks away when
somebody says well who's going to do it
then so one of the things with the world
fair first newsletter was the feedback
from our technicians in the field that a
lot of the information that we were
putting out about head-office days and
what staff were doing from for charities
etc wasn't really relevant to them and
was of interest but wasn't as much
interest as perhaps articles on animal
welfare so really very much for
ourselves we started a welfare first
newsletter where we blog our industry
news used for the updates about animals
of advanced science and articles really
relevant to the technicians for the
technicians but most importantly written
by the technicians and what started off
as a a very good internal and a vessel
for communicating information quickly
expanded into we're now doing the world
prefers to e-newsletter for about 10
companies within the UK
want to reach out for their staff so
that's been a real positive unexpected
side effect from communicating with our
staff we're finding the other we're
engaging much more with it with the
teams
the other thing that was really
important for us as well is to be open
about the work we do and so if you go on
to our web sites at any point there's
testimonials there from some of the
technicians that work with this and how
we can help solve a problem and in terms
of contract staffing and permanent
recruitment but more importantly just
really about the culture of the
organization I won't dwell on that
because I want what I'd like to do is
just talk about concepts to do a welfare
first rather than necessarily
specifically what gender can do for you
so the important thing for us and what
we've seen on the ground is more of our
staff are now engaged in the units that
they work in in the businesses more
people are generating and posters for us
which is always great we've certainly
seen the number of posters increased
generally at meetings we've been too
late and we're no different just talking
about what people really think about
animal welfare and research which which
I alluded to earlier on and some of the
career pathways that are available so
what is all this mean for us because we
started this process about three or four
years ago and we were delighted to win
the UA our openness award in 2016 for
our engagement with the sector it's very
important for us to continue this
engagement and that that's why I was
delighted obviously to be given the
opportunity to give a brief overview of
our program what is it really meant for
us because as a concept I think it's
something that's near and dear to a
number of people's hearts certainly when
we started it three or four years ago at
less people were engaging with the staff
in this way I think I've certainly seen
over the last two to three years more
and more companies talk about engaging
staff making welfare first and foremost
and actually I think is the openness
agender has come through I think as an
industry it's been much more positive
for us and enabled us
to talk about the work that we do in an
environment that's not threatened I know
that that's different in different parts
of the world and but certainly within
the UK at the moment and it's a very
open environment and it gives us the
opportunity to engage with stakeholders
like NC three hours and you AR and in
order to get our ideas across and and
engagements really helped us and took to
reach out for our staff and at this
stage and of course we are talking about
people as I started the presentation and
people are people people may always give
you challenges but right now with over
110 I think now an update from from the
previous slide technicians that we have
we really feel it's working well it's
enabling us to reach out to our
technicians help them in different
environments and we're looking forward
to as always with our business to
evolving it and take it to the next
level so thank you Alex
and I'm happy to take any questions at
this point I hope a lot of that was self
explanatory but please don't hesitate to
contact me
thank you Tim for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your on your screen and click the send
button once there's many questions as we
have time for now let's get started our
first question is what was the driver
for developing your welfare first
program thank you and I think the key
thing for us was we have a number of
technicians in in different locations
and rather like a number of you on this
call with multiple locations either
within the same country or on a global
basis we felt it was an increasing
challenge to really reach out to them
particularly some of the people in and
where there was perhaps one or two
technicians so the main tour IVA really
was we wanted to connect people across
the UK and Europe we wanted to give them
something to talk about which they could
contribute to and I think the
combination of actually giving them an
opportunity to contribute on the animal
welfare and perspective reo articles as
well as obviously give them an
opportunity if they've got concerns in
one of the placements that they're
working out so it worked very well for
us and on to two counts I balance of the
question our next question is how has it
been received and what practical
improvements have you seen I might
answer that with the previous question -
thank you for that and it essentially
our technicians very happy with the
world for the first program I think
we've been able to communicate with our
our staff in a much more productive way
we've been able to give them updates on
courses animal welfare issues changes on
legislation so from a practical point of
view from a CPD continuing professional
development perspective it's been
very very positive so yes very well so
far accepting that as we evolved we'll
have to find it a more modern way of
communicating with the breath by mobile
phones and and we'll need to look at the
way we communicate going forward because
as we know what was working well in 16
and 17 may not be so effective in 2018
with the way technology moves and it
looks like nearsighted how does this
program sit with partner organizations
okay thank you yeah this is a good
question and because obviously and our
welfare first is is driven by two or
three different things one was for us to
look after our technicians as a business
employing people we wanted to look after
him so that was one of the key defined
areas the second one was giving our
technicians an opportunity to raise a
concern or question anything so that's
quite a tricky and dilemma when you're
placing people to work in other
facilities
but the answer is very well because they
understand my caste that we've got
commitment around animal welfare we have
a very transparent open relationship
with our clients across Europe and so
from a program point of view from a
management from having access to our
technicians in our other partner
facilities this works very well so I
feel that and and it's always difficult
to speak for other companies certainly
the companies that we've interacted with
very happy with the welfare first
program and I think I mentioned too we
now have 10 people who have signed up to
the newsletter which they utilize for
their own staff so and what one is
assuming that the level of communication
and commitment is being received
positively
I would like to once again oops
I'd like to once again thank Tim for his
presentation I'd also like to thank a
gender Lifesciences for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2018
you will receive an email from laborat
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye